Los denunciantes son atacados.
Esto se demuestra en todos los titulares.
Mucha gente elige no convertirse en denunciantes
por miedo a las represalias.
Desde ser relegados a un cargo menor, a amenazas de muerte,
a pérdida del trabajo...
pérdidas de trabajo permanentes.
Elegir convertirse en denunciante es una batalla cuesta arriba.
Se cuestiona su lealtad.
Sus motivos, su credibilidad.
Así que ¿cómo puedo yo, como profesora que se preocupa por su alumnos,
animarlos a que se conviertan en denunciantes
cuando sé lo que realmente piensa el mundo de ellos?
Un día me estaba preparando para mi clase anual sobre denuncias
con mis alumnos,
y estaba escribiendo un artículo para "Forbes"
titulado "Wells Fargo y los denunciantes mileniales. ¿Qué les decimos?".
Y mientras trabajaba en ese artículo y leía sobre el caso,
me enfadé muchísimo.
Y lo que me enfadó fue el darme cuenta
de que los empleados que intentaron hacer denuncias
fueron despedidos.
Y me hizo pensar
en el mensaje que estaba compartiendo con mis alumnos.
Y me hizo pensar: ¿y si mis alumnos hubieran sido empleados de Wells Fargo?
Por un lado, si hubieran hecho la denuncia, los habrían despedido.
Pero por otro lado,
si no hubiesen informado de los fraudes que conocían,
tal y como está la legislación,
se responsabiliza a los empleados si saben algo y no informan.
Así que la acción penal es una opción real.
¿Qué se supone que debe hacer uno con esas posibilidades?
Yo más que nadie sé lo valiosas que son las contribuciones
que hacen los denunciantes.
De hecho, la mayoría de los fraudes los descubren ellos.
El 42 % de los fraudes los destapan los denunciantes,
en comparación con otros métodos
como la revisión de mediciones y las auditorías externas.
Y si piensan en algunos de los casos emblemáticos o históricos de fraudes,
siempre giran en torno a un denunciante.
Piensen en el Watergate, descubierto por un denunciante.
Piensen en Enron, descubierto por un denunciante.
¿Y cómo olvidar a Bernard Madoff, descubierto por un denunciante?
Hace falta tener mucho valor para dar un paso al frente en nombre de la verdad.
Pero cuando pensamos en el término "denunciante",
normalmente pensamos en palabras muy descriptivas:
rata,
serpiente,
traidor,
soplón,
comadreja.
Y esas son las palabras bonitas, las que puedo usar en este escenario.
Cuando no estoy en clase,
recorro el país entrevistando a delincuentes de guante blanco,
denunciantes y víctimas de fraude.
Porque estoy intentando entender qué los mueve
para llevar esas experiencias a la clase.
Pero las entrevistas que de verdad me marcan son las de los denunciantes.
Y me marcan
porque me hacen cuestionar mi propia valentía.
Si yo tuviera la oportunidad, ¿hablaría?
Hay un par de historias que quiero compartir con Uds.
Esta es Mary.
Mary Willingham es la denunciante de la Universidad de Carolina del Norte
en Chapel Hill, un caso de fraude académico.
Mary era especialista en aprendizaje en la universidad
y trabajaba con estudiantes, principalmente con atletas.
Y mientras trabajaba con ellos, Mary descubrió
que sus trabajos finales
parecían estar por encima de su nivel de lectura.
Empezó a hacer un par de preguntas y descubrió que había una base de datos
de donde estos alumnos sacaban información para hacer sus trabajos.
Y luego descubrió que algunos de sus colegas
colaban alumnos en clases "falsas" solo para que tuvieran derecho a jugar.
Cuando Mary lo descubrió, se enfadó mucho.
Y lo que intentó hacer fue ir a su supervisor inmediato.
Pero no hicieron nada.
Y luego Mary intentó acudir a los administradores de la universidad.
Y no hicieron nada.
¿Y qué pasa cuando nadie escucha?
Escribes un blog.
Así que Mary decidió crear un blog.
Su blog se hizo viral en 24 horas y un periodista la contactó.
Cuando este periodista la contactó, su identidad se dio a conocer.
Estaba expuesta.
Y cuando quedó expuesta, fue relegada a un cargo menor,
y recibió amenazas de muerte por este tema de los deportes.
Mary no hizo nada malo. No participó en el fraude.
Realmente pensaba que daría voz a los estudiantes que no la tenían.
Pero se cuestionó su lealtad,
su confianza y sus motivos.
Pero los denunciantes no siempre acaban
siendo rebajados en su cargo o recibiendo amenazas de muerte.
De hecho, en 2002, esta fue la portada de la revista "Time",
que alababa a tres valientes denunciantes
por su decisión de dar un paso al frente en nombre de la verdad.
Y si ven la investigación,
el 22 % de los denunciantes afirman que sufren represalias.
Así que hay un gran número de gente que informa y no sufre represalias
y eso me da esperanza.
Esta es Kathe.
Kathe Swanson es secretaria municipal jubilada en la ciudad de Dixon.
Un día, Kathe estaba haciendo su trabajo como siempre
y se topó con un caso muy interesante.
Era el final del mes
y Kathe estaba haciendo el informe contable de la ciudad
y como siempre, su jefa, Rita Crundwell, le dio una lista de las cuentas y le dijo:
"Kathe, llama al banco y pide información de estas cuentas".
Y Kathe hizo su trabajo.
Pero ese día en concreto
Rita no estaba en la ciudad y Kathe estaba ocupada.
Así que toma el teléfono, llama al banco y dice: "Envía por fax todas las cuentas".
Y cuando llega el fax, ve que hay una cuenta
que registraba el ingreso y egreso de fondos
de los que no tenía conocimiento.
Era una cuenta que solo controlaba Rita.
Así que Kathe miró la información, informó a su supervisor inmediato,
que entonces era el alcalde Burke,
y eso llevó a una investigación enorme, una investigación de seis meses.
Resulta que la jefa de Kathe, Rita Crundwell,
estaba malversando fondos.
Rita había malversado USD 53 millones en un período de 20 años
y Kathe lo descubrió sin querer.
Kathe es una heroína.
Y de hecho, tuve la oportunidad
de entrevistar a Kathe para mi documental "All the Queen's Horses".
Kathe no buscaba fama.
De hecho, durante mucho tiempo no quiso hablar conmigo,
pero, gracias a un acecho estratégico, al final accedió.
(Risas)
Pero ella buscaba justicia, no fama.
Y si no fuera por Kathe,
quién sabe si se habría descubierto el fraude alguna vez.
¿Recuerdan ese artículo de "Forbes" del que hablé,
en el que trabajaba antes de mi clase?
Pues lo publiqué y pasó algo fantástico.
Comencé a recibir correos de denunciantes de todo el mundo.
Y a medida que recibía esos correos y les enviaba una respuesta,
había un tema común en los mensajes
y era este:
"Yo hice la denuncia y ahora la gente me odia.
Me despidieron, ¿pero saben qué?
Si pudiera, lo haría otra vez".
A medida que leía todos los mensajes,
pensaba: ¿qué puedo compartir con mis alumnos?
Así que lo junté todo y esto es lo que aprendí.
Es importante que cultivemos la esperanza.
Los denunciantes nos dan esperanza.
Al contrario de lo que se piensa,
no todos son empleados insatisfechos que tienen un problema con la empresa.
Su esperanza es lo que los lleva a dar un paso al frente.
También tenemos que fomentar el compromiso.
Los denunciantes están comprometidos.
Y es esa pasión por su organización lo que los lleva a dar un paso al frente.
Los denunciantes son humildes.
Insisto, no buscan fama pero sí buscan justicia.
Y tenemos que seguir fomentando la valentía.
Los denunciantes son valientes.
A menudo subestiman
el impacto que el hecho de denunciar tiene en su familia,
pero siguen insistiendo en lo difícil que es guardarse la verdad.
Quiero dejarlos con un nombre más:
Peter Buxtun.
Peter Buxton era un empleado de 27 años del sistema público de salud de EE. UU.
Y fue contratado para entrevistar a gente
que tenía enfermedades de transmisión sexual.
Y durante su trabajo,
le llamó la atención un estudio clínico que estaban haciendo en la organización.
Era un estudio que investigaba la progresión de la sífilis no tratada.
En el estudio, había 600 hombres afroestadounidenses
que fueron persuadidos a participar
a cambio de exámenes médicos gratuitos y seguros de sepelio.
Y durante el estudio
se descubrió que la penicilina ayudaba a curar la sífilis.
Y Peter vio que a los participantes del estudio no les habían dado penicilina
para tratar su sífilis.
Y los participantes no lo sabían.
Así que al igual que Mary, Peter intentó informar a sus supervisores internos,
pero nadie lo escuchó.
Y Peter pensaba que era muy injusto, así que intentó informar de nuevo,
y al final acabó hablando con un periodista, igual que Mary.
Y en 1972 esta fue la portada del "New York Times":
"Personas con sífilis en un estudio en EE. UU. no fueron tratadas en 40 años".
Hoy en día se lo conoce como el "experimento Tuskegee".
Y Peter fue el denunciante.
¿Qué pasó con los 600 hombres, con los participantes originales?
Veintiocho hombres murieron de sífilis.
Cien murieron por complicaciones derivadas de la sífilis,
cuarenta y cinco esposas se contagiaron
y 10 niños nacieron con sífilis congénita.
Quién sabe cuáles serían los números
si no hubiera sido por el valiente acto de Peter.
De hecho, todos estamos conectados con Peter.
Si conocen a alguien que esté en un estudio clínico,
la razón por la que hoy existe el consentimiento informado
es gracias al valiente acto de Peter.
Déjenme hacerles una pregunta.
Esa pregunta del principio, una variación de la pregunta original.
¿Cuántos de nosotros hemos usado los términos
bocaza,
rata,
soplón,
serpiente,
comadreja,
sabandija?
¿Nadie?
Antes de que sientan ganas de hacerlo otra vez,
quiero que lo piensen antes.
Puede que sean las Mary, los Peter o las Kathe del mundo.
Pueden ser la persona que dé forma a la historia
o ellos pueden ser las personas que den forma a la suya.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)